let's go next to Jack from Pennsylvania
Jack from Pennsylvania welcome what's on
your mind today
hello David for
um well I think I first want to start
off like I said like a scenario here
um well first actually do you think it's
possible
um if the other two parties grow more
divided between like democrats for
example the progressive and the moderate
camp and the Republicans the modern the
market Camp they think it's possible to
see like something like like what
happens in a Whig party in the 1800s
where like the entire party collapses
for like the um it like splits up into
two other parties I do think it is
possible but the very entrenched system
we have for the major parties including
uh financing and commission on
presidential debates and all of these
other status quo entrenchments that we
have would make it much more difficult
to see what happened to the Whig party
it's possible but I don't see it as
likely
to one of the other parties let's say
that they're lay magas and they say like
the Republican party like collapses do
you think it'll be smart for it to
progress for the progressive uh caucus
in the Democratic Party
hello
all right we lost Jack Jack was getting
through some follow-up but we lost him
with a very strange digital noise right
at that moment let's go next to Edward
from Colorado Edward from Colorado
welcome to the program uh what's on your
mind today
hi there David can you hear me okay yes
I can
okay so I had a question
a patrol
I couldn't do some presidential
candidates
you're you're cutting in and out Edward
you said you had a question about
presidential candidates
about a potential Gavin Newsom candidacy
oh okay go ahead
so I guess
with him
do you feel like uh
like the severity of California's covet
lockdowns would kind of thing
oh my God Edward you're cutting in and
out with the severity of the lockdowns
do what
do you think it would be a substantive
enough criticism that it would hurt him
substantially electorally no I don't
all right Edward the connection is
atrocious so I'm going to let you go
it's just it's very very very very very
bad